in 2012 during the violence there were a
number of bodies dumped by government
trucks in this area over here dead
Rohingya bodies buried in a mass grave
[Music]
we know that there has been widespread
and systematic rape over a hundred women
not only by state security forces but
also by other citizens that were working
in collusion with security forces is a
strong case to be made that there are
state forces at play fomenting
anti-muslim sentiment and in the case of
Roja fomenting violence that could
amount to the crime of genocide
mother after a mother Syria Gary McCord
of everybody Vanessa Takaaki the boy
adored Orion aza
we have no way to provide him anything
has he always been like this or just
since after the conflict up to thousands
of people came back
[Music]
yes yes Annette and that's that's a
natural idea that got me super wide
mouth she's got something out
[Music]
it's national level government involved
in essentially orchestrating what are
avoidable deprivation in in basic aid
before these people so in many ways this
is not only a situation in which
conditions of life are being created to
destroy people but in some cases people
see no other option but to flee the
country
[Music]